the range of interesting talks societal
networks is being broadly defined you
know maybe with focal points and in
energy and transportation communications
to a lesser extent but but but all over
it's really a question of a special time
in the evolution of our science that
brings together models and data and
algorithms and interesting ways with
with all kinds of real world impact and
one I extra notes that Peter omitted
that probe in Berea and in an early
stage of the discussion he couldn't be
here Frank Kelly we're also part of the
organizing committee for the workshop so
I want to extend my thanks to them and
on with the show so our first speaker is
fair fight and as you can see he's going
to talk about this new caste resource
area network for electric vehicle
charging you David thank you all for
your organizers for the invitation and
it's an honor actually to be the first
speaker of this great workshop and I was
really looking forward it's a long time
and I did everything I could to be here
so I'm going to talk to you today about
about the topic this is kind of for me
like a breaking point between the past
and the future like like my background
is applied probability in Hughes and I
says a couple of years I got really
interested in power systems working all
the reliability aspects for for a bit
and then I came across electric vehicles
and I so I'm just curious to see what
you think so this joint work which angle
Ozark lorries with a PhD student code
advised by Maria Rossi you and me at the
University of Iowa where I'm one day per
week so motivation you probably all know
that the electric vehicles are on the
rise and will continue to rise and you
to all sorts of drivers especially the
cost of battery getting cheaper but of
course all kinds of policy developments
in policy and so on and so like you can
expect it's going to stay and and there
is a lot of effort going on trying to
understand the impacts and what we have
to do to make this transitioning
happening and so there are like atomo
all kinds of different ways of charging
your vehicle if you charge it at home
typically you go sleep and you don't
really care from minute to minute on how
fast your your car is being charged as
long as you wake up you want to be able
to drive to work it's similar to a
fridge right if you open a fridge I
think shall mine once said that you open
the fridge so you you don't want to
smell anything and the light shoot shoot
work and it's kind of like in terms of
communication that works similar to two
best-effort traffic light if you if you
want to download data as opposed to
voice where you really want to have a
good quality to a lesser extent if you
go shop this is a exhibition of the
Dutch parking skills in Amsterdam then
you wanna have like maybe a slightly
faster rate of charging then then on the
bottom left we see a Dutch company
called Fastnet they're opening all kinds
of fast charging stations next to Dutch
highways and there you can really charge
your car in in maybe 10 minutes and
Tesla has superchargers that can make
your car charge in five minutes and I
guess this is all gone and be able to go
faster and faster last but not least
that it's also possible sometimes to
swap batteries I'm not going to talk
about that today but it's also an
interesting way of thinking about how to
deal with this I guess in the future I
don't know if somebody's going to talk
about that you could even imagine that
everybody's just sharing all kinds of
cars and you just like as we did with
horses you just instead of switching
horses you just switch cars maybe that
will happen in your future but like I
don't think like for example with my
kids making so much dirt in I don't
think it's gonna happen that anybody
wants to share my car but okay so I'm
gonna go to mostly talk about the type
of charging which is the the first to
slow charging today so what are so at
least in a municipality of Amsterdam
they really they care a lot about where
to put these charging stations for
example if you own the rest
once you care about like what type of
charging stations we want like the
University of Iowa where I am they're
gonna build a new parking lot they care
about how many charging stations do they
need I mean they actually ask them for
their data that just gave all their data
to me of all the charging stations up to
now it's they were quite eager to share
it and to see if we can find something
I'm not going to talk about this today
but like I think it's like it's like
these all capacity expansion problems
also the ability to charge a battery
fastest that's something that people
worry about like in now you go you take
your car you put gasoline in it ideally
with should be as fast as as as a
traditional gasoline II that will help
people transition however suppose we are
all able to do this so suppose that we
put millions of charging stations
everywhere and our batteries can charge
that at let's say infinite speed like
are we going to be happy then the answer
is no like then it's just the bottleneck
at least that's the motivation of this
talk the bottleneck is going to shift to
the grid itself so this is a I don't
know if somebody's from low hum is
watching the livestream but so I will
not say anything funny about it but it's
like a remote it's a remote part of the
Netherlands let's say the New Mexico of
the Netherlands where we experiment with
our energy and it's actually very nice a
region here and so they actually they
looked at a scenario 2025 where people
come home from work hungry with an empty
battery so they want to charge their car
and bake a pizza so the the the the
distribution company offered free
champagne breakfast if they were able to
to burn something and so they tried and
the experiment started at 7 o'clock so
you I don't know if this works
but like actually the first hop at
around throughout 702 you see a drop in
voltage at the bottom that's one Tesla
connecting Italy like one Tesla
connecting your voltage drop five volts
so it's kind of pretty significant so
like they charge more and more cars and
then at around at some point they start
baking pizzas and so around a little bit
after a today they add one more Tesla to
the network and then they broke
something so this is somewhere between
2005 this is like I was not involved in
this experience those are colleagues
from the University of Twente so they
broke something so they they caused
something that could not have been
prevented with existing control
mechanisms now this is based on a 2025
scenario so yeah we need to we need to
think about I mean the topic of this
workshop is a butane message making we
need to think about how to to manage
this right there's going to be there's
going to be problems even in a Dutch
grid which i think is quite good
compared to some other countries okay so
alright so that that's kind of like some
broad motivational talk so I'm going to
talk about so the way I see it as an
applied problem list that evie charging
is a very nice playground of stochastic
processes all interacting networks so
you have the you have the the
electricity network obviously you have
also road network and then we need to
manage we need to manage that with a
communication network on top it's kind
of like everything everything is here so
of course we have to model so we're
going to look at a charging stations
which so you can think of it as a
queuing network where every node it's a
parking lot and there are ki parking
spaces cars arrive according to Poisson
process of rate lambda I they have some
characteristics each car has some like
characteristics which we model with a
bivariate probability distribution B and
D so charging requirement be parking
time the
you can imagine that if you arrived you
you fill out this information on the
charging station so we're I'm gonna
assume that this is known I'm gonna also
assume that cars that cannot that find a
food parking lot are lost which is kind
of you could also extend the model some
of the results at least you recently can
be extended that people try to park
something out somewhere else if I if I
see what happens on the TV campus there
only a very limited number of parking
lots for electric cars and then if
they're all fool you always have the
option to park on a position where there
is no charging station but so in this
model we assume that the cars that let's
find a pool fool Lots so parking K ice
parking spaces in this context means ki
parking spaces where there is the
possibility to charge your vehicle
okay so bivariate distribution for
charging requirements of parking time so
then I'm gonna keep track on the number
of electric vehicles at every parking
lot and then also the number of vehicles
that are not yet charged and what I'm
what we are interested in is how to
charge those cars while keeping voltage
troop bounded yes how much he wants your
battery to be charged yes
any other questions
No so that's a very that's an excellent
question
so there are for example if I go back to
this picture this for example what you
refer like there are different ways of
like this fast charging as fast that you
would have like a very limited number of
cars charging their cars the fast rate
all the cars will wait in a queue I'm
not looking at that I'm more looking at
a case where there are where this is not
happening so wherever the charging will
be a little bit slower but I'll go in
more detail later so actually when I'm
teaching queueing I and iit-jee Erlang
loss model so first of all like for
those of you know a little bit of
queueing if I look at the case where we
don't have to charge the cars and there
is just one parking lot it's an hour
long loss model okay also like if if
there's just one parking lot
if there is one parking lot of infinite
size and and the parking times are
infinitely longer they're just customers
leave after they are charged it's going
to be processor sharing queue this is
how I'm going to model the single node
single class but I'm going to look at
the multi class extension of that this
is a side remark I'll come back to that
later
so there's actually not that much work
like probably I missed it but like a lot
like Larson as a paper or where he's
looking at parking lots and he's using
or long-lost Mo's but they are not that
much there's not that much work Elena
Judah Nova has worked or something
that's more fast-charging she looks at
some kind of ideas that are reminiscent
of what other people like Shrikant and
also story are I've worked on and others
closer to the typical stochastic
networks like the the max weight type of
algorithms or apply to fast charging but
not really taking into account voltage
drops one motivation for the study is
paper where Frank also one of the
organizers of these works will be
involved in is a paper
we're actually they actually look at the
mobile that we are looking at and they
they don't have they don't have a pro
bono parking lot so they don't have
impatience in they don't have a the
model that people are leaving because
they simply are done shopping or
something and then they simulate the
simulated system so they they run
simulations but no math and in that
model
so James Cruz and seifish near from
Edinburgh are looking at the stability
condition of their model an American
assumption so it's almost finished and I
think it's going to be nice work bug
them because otherwise they might not
finish it all right
hi James so alright so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna like one of the things I'm
gonna do at least for the purpose of
this talk I'm gonna look at tractable
load flow model so first of all like I
showed you these these graphs of these
experiments where we're keeping all the
three phases we're not going to do that
so I'm not gonna model frequency I'm
gonna look at like a quasi steady state
process where I'm just focusing on
voltage and like this so we're talking
about electric vehicles so you're in the
distribution grid which is a tree
network and in the tree network like the
AC power flow equations are pretty
tractable but for at least for this talk
I'm gonna make a further simplification
and I'm gonna model the the voltages in
the network with linearized this flow
which I learned when I was visiting
Caltech and so I'm gonna so essentially
if you look at a line network the the
linearized dis flow approximation the
the voltage drop like if you park your
car twice as far like you have two
options you park it in the middle of the
network or at the ends then that would
lead to a voltage drop that would be
twice as big so it is like that's that's
how you can think about this is
approximation so you typically you sum
up over all the vehicles that take power
I'm also I'm not actually in this model
considering the fact that other people
are using outcome we can talk about this
later so I'm just focusing on the
electric vehicles alone in a system
I'll later go to the special case of a
lion topology where these formulas are
going to be a little bit simpler all
right so some of our results are comment
on that like Holt also for many more
general AC so I'm also not only so that
I'm only considering active power here
like it is reasonable in a sense that
the batteries of the cars only need
active power but the equations like it
would be more interesting as an
extension to also consider the fact that
you can support a voltage drop with a
reactive power support but it's not at
the moment in the middle okay so the
question now is suppose we have a static
situation are we going to charge the car
we have seen exactly you have a question
like yeah I normalized everything so
it's a good question but that kind of
normalized everything so I assume that
at the feeder for example you have 240
volts at the feeder of the network and
we want to stay within 10% of that of
that bounce so everything is going to be
relative to what what is yet the node of
the network where where we have the
connection with a higher voltage grid
yeah so the Z's are going to be dynamic
and then the piece also they're going to
be a function of Z I'm gonna explain it
now and then you have like this function
that gives you the voltages alright so
this is something that people in the
stochastic network community are more
familiar with but all those probably not
so I'm gonna look at this so suppose we
have a static situation and we have we
have a vector describing a number of
uncharged vehicles in the network and we
need to charge them and we need to
decide how much power to allocate to all
of these vehicles so what we are going
to do is we're gonna we're going to say
that if we're going to charge power to
one particular vehicle in one particular
point in time we we assign this utility
for example this weighted logarithmic
utility and then we're going to maximize
the the sum of all the utilities subject
to the fact that we
we can only charge batteries at a
certain rate and we were not allowed to
burn any fuses and we want to keep the
voltage drop we want to keep the voltage
drop within limits acceptable limits
this is the type of allocation mechanism
so you can there's a lot of things to be
said here in a sense that it's kind of a
myopic strategy it looks a little bit
like what opf is doing however here you
would you would like to decide you would
like to assign your utility based on how
much time you stay in a system to be
parked and how much additional power you
need to fill your battery with so it's
kind of but you can you can fix this by
by extending this model to a multi class
model where you you jump from one class
to another based on where you are with
your profile and that so the like so for
the purpose of this talk I keep it
single class so this is the static
situation so this is so when you look at
the linearize this flow this is a pretty
nice optimization problem if a UI is
assumed to be strictly concave in
general for general AC this is still
pretty nice in the sense that it's
convex relaxation gives you the exact
solution because it's a tree network and
Stephen law in one of his surveys it
falls under the under that framework so
so that works so of course like these
utility functions where you get them
from so Frank did a lot of working
communication networks in here it should
be a little bit easier because like we
have this LPF style of problems already
but you can imagine that cars will have
their batteries will be operated by
software and they're going to decide
based on prices how fast they're going
to charge so there's still a lot of room
for improvement here in the in
formulation but so we're just going to
take this as given and then see how
we're doing in this talk yes
in power but the energy demand is
yeah let's hear like I I'm an imposter
actually I'm not really an electrical
engineer but yeah you need to be careful
in defining these things properly so
that's a that's another excellent
question so I assume that I am solving
this instantaneously and when I so yeah
that will give a lot of communication
overhead and I think if you want to
implement this you should solve it every
minute and then the constraints the
voltage constraint should be a chance
core strength probably but that that
will make it harder but right now I
assume that somebody is solving this for
me at every instance in time I'm gonna
look at a continuous-time model so but
yeah I practice you you want to solve
this as discrete instance and then
there's going to be a trade-off in the
reliability vs. communication overhead
and I'm not considering that right now
yeah yeah they will
this is very simple version other
questions
physical meaning of what it's the it's
the instant rewards I assign as a
consumer for being served at this rate
so no that would like if you if you want
a model that you need to multi class
extension for example you see how much
time do I keep how much time do I stay
part in the system versus how much more
energy do I need you look at that ratio
based on that you make a decision you
could do that but then it would be that
would be more complicated notation but
in particular I mean in principle if we
chunk it up into finitely many segments
of this ratio our model will be able to
handle it but I'm just giving a similar
version yeah that's true
so they're not here not a day that
should be they should be included if you
want to move closer to practice you need
to include the pizzas the buildings
everything yeah they are not here true
so that also makes it simpler in the
sense that so that yeah these
constraints yeah you you probably the
model should be way more complicated
other questions all right so the model
should be more complicated but instead
let's make it for at least for a second
a little bit simpler so the question is
like is there like from like like I'm a
QA I'm in a queueing bed round so are
there like instances where you can find
an explicit solution of this model the
answer is yes so if the only constraint
is the voltage drop so the the top two
constraints here are not active and they
are like if you need many parking lots
saying you take the the logarithmic
unweighted logarithmic utility function
then the system essentially reduces to a
multi-class process is sharing queue so
that is like
but that that seems to be in the case of
an online network that seems to be the
only case where so where you can imagine
that so the the connection with the
process is sharing as I said this is a
service discipline where we charge where
we we serve all customers at the same
rate and the idea here is that if I park
at node I my effective service time is
the amount of energy I need multiplied
with the sum of the resistances across
the line from that node to the feeder I
need to multiply it with that and then
and then you can see it as a multi class
processor sharing queue and provided
that some stability condition holds and
ok but that's about that's about it so
so processor sharing was suggested in
the past for several other applications
like communication networks and also the
original application was a mainframe
computer systems ok but in general it's
not that easy so if you I mean the model
is very simple but if you if you keep in
mind that there is also stochastic
dynamic stochastic dynamics going on so
what you get is like at every given
moment of time you have a you have a
measure valued processor where like for
every node we are we're keeping track of
the cars as particles and they are
interacting because of the scheduling
discipline they're interacting and all
these particles move to the to the
Southwest at a certain rate depending on
so they're because they're there they're
parking time is expiring at a constant
rate but there is interaction in how you
charge the car so it's very complicated
especially if you if you don't want to
assume exponential service times and
even if you do what when assume
exponential service times then the
Markov chain is pretty ugly
so you actually this is a typo so you
you need to you need to solve of the
order of K to the power to our convex
optimization problems just to fill the
rate matrix the Q matrix so for every
element you need to solve an
optimization problem what I usually do
in this case is I send an email to our
cardi nemirovsky asking what should I do
and you asked so yeah basically I mean
we we are going to show you some
examples for the case of two notes and K
is equal to 50 you recommended just to
solve them one by one but like it's the
optimization problems are very similar
in the sense that you check you slightly
change the criterion function you put a
little jet iron and you'll say Diane
it's like you basically says like if
it's of the order of billions then don't
bother but if it's going to be like 10
to the power 12 or more you should do
something else but like even then it's
like if you have no exponential
distributions then that's just hopeless
so we do something else and and that's
we're going to approximate things with a
fluid so this is I did not make this
picture myself there was like at some
point I some artists I wrote some
popular scientific article about fluid
approximations and then there was
somebody drew this so the idea is gonna
we're going to approximate these
particles with a fluid and so you can do
this in multiple ways you can do this
formally self formally I mean with
formally I'm a mathematician I mean
really formally not formally as if you
don't make it rigorous but like okay you
can consider it any way you want but if
you want to do this you need to look at
a scale system or Mullens index by N and
you can scale up the capacity you can
scale up the arrival rate you can scale
up the number of parking rates and then
you if you do that you can expect some
in the limit some deterministic
dynamical system to appear and then and
then you would like to study its
invariant point so I'm not going to go
into how to make this all rigorous and
I'll just give you a result on how the
invariant point of the system would look
so it turns out that if you do this type
of scaling you can characterize so you
can so we have looked at this opf type
of problem and on top of that you have
done the stochastic dynamics but it
turns out that if you do this type of
fluid scaling and at least the invariant
points
complexity which is very similar to the
original scheduling discipline in a
static case so that's good and so the
result is that is this in varying points
that star can be expressed in terms of
the solution of an optimization problem
which is as I said very similar to the
OPF platform before just with a
different criterion function and a
criterion function has some information
about the Joint Distribution of the
charging in the parking times as well
and as the the utility function and so
everything is there the the network
constrains the network is in the
constraint so you have like the
stochastic dynamics the utility
functions and and the physical network
restraints are all in this optimization
program and G is concave so this is good
you can solve this it's just not 10 to
the power 12 o-p-s which is 1 it's good
and so how do you do this so you can
actually from that compute the fraction
of cars and get successfully charged if
you know the Joint Distribution so how
to do this so that's the idea is like a
QE we always used to say in queueing
theory little is known but little is
known so we are going to apply for the
purpose of this talk we're going to
apply littles law you Rishta cailli so
littles law says that the expected
number of customers in the system is the
arrival rate times the time you spent in
the system so a rival rate here is just
a rival rate in in Erlang loss system so
we take we take we know that that's this
gamma I and then how much time you will
spend in the system well this how much
time I spend in this system is the
minimum of my parking time and the time
I am considered to be an uncharged
vehicle now the time I am considered to
be an uncharged vehicle is the amount of
energy I need divided by the rate I get
the energy Steve thank you for
correcting my terminology again so so
how much what is the rate well in in
steady state we're thinking of a big
system everything is balanced so you
canyou ristic we apply the snapshot
principle that you you stay in a system
for a very
relatively short time so your rate is
gonna be this P I of Jetstar so if you
don't plug this in you get a you get an
equation and you want to solve this
equation and usually you you try to do
some contraction mapping argument but
that doesn't work here but what you can
do is and this is a trick that I learned
from all the work of Frank Kelly on most
networks but I mean it hasn't peered in
other settings as well so you add this
approximate version of Latos law to the
KKT conditions for the optimization
problem that divides P of Z you massage
the whole thing and then it turns out
that you did this this new set of
equations so the old KKT condition and
then for Jetstar and anna's equation for
Jetstar you can from that whole set of
equations recognize that that is
actually the set of KKT conditions of
this problem you have to guess it but I
mean if you've seen it once you you you
know how to do it so that's kind of the
way you you show this that actually
still works for AC then you have to you
have to be a little bit more careful but
the fact that the convex relaxation is
exactly helps in this case so this whole
thing would still work for a more
general form oh so yes yeah like because
like I look at the linearized this flow
so the capacity the the set over which i
optimize here is actually polyhedral
the function G is also you can use some
probability theory to show that that G
because it's a composition of a concave
function with the inverse of this
expected value function and you can show
you this concave so we did some we did
some little validation so we compare
first of all we I mean you can see also
if this is just if you only have a lot
of ol tidge constraint is the only
constraint just a little network of a
line network of two parking lots we we
computed the expected number of jobs in
a system everything is exponential and
compared to the dis flow approximation
with AC and so you see that this flow at
least for this purposes seems to be a
reasonable approximation then we
compared we look also at the fluid
approximations both for this lower AC
and we compare them with with the
expected value we compared with each
other use also see that here also the
impact of approximating AC with this
flow is not going to harm you that much
the question of course is how good is
the fluid approximation to the
stochastic model that's also pretty good
it gets worse if you add all the
capacity constraints but it still within
10 percent relative error I mean for for
bigger systems so we cannot really
compute the whole Markov chain invariant
distribution anymore so then the obvious
question then it's like okay how do we
the next question is that like how I'm
gonna you can use this to set the
weights in a utility function so so
consider now setting where you these
utility functions are logarithmic with
weights and then the question is how to
set those weights so the first thing you
may wonder is how to set the weights in
in a way that everybody gets charged at
the same rate and then then that really
depends on how far you are from the
connection to the high voltage grid like
the further away you are the bigger
weights you should get
otherwise otherwise you're not getting
charged a lot so but that's not very
efficient so another type of question
you can wonder is like how can we set
the weights in such a way to maximize
the throughput and again weighted
proportional fairness and the weight
should be different you can play a
little a little bit with this
optimization problem and then you you
get this type of resource allocation
problem
so the fraction of cars that is charged
successfully at the parking lot I or
line not the fraction but the total
number of cars the rate of cars that
discharged successfully note eyes didn't
this gamma I times this probability and
the weights appear there and a subject
to constraint which the voltage drop
which looks then like this and you can
then depending on the Joint Distribution
of being they try to solve this and so
I'll give you two examples on how the
solution looks out the first kind of
thing we looked at is that B is equal to
a deterministic constant times D so
everybody expects to get charged at a
certain rate it is proportional to the
amount of time they are parking if you
look at that so it's actually
interesting example because this is
actually the the distribution that
achieves the distribution really robust
solution to this problem if I if I want
to do distribution your robust
optimization subject to the fact that
that B and D have given means and I
solve this problem then it turns out
that this is a this is distribution of
your bus solution so let that give you a
knapsack style problem and you see from
this problem is that this knapsack
problem is that people who are going to
park down the street will get in trouble
if there is a if there is an overload in
the network which is something you you
yeah you need to be aware of at least I
mean it's a very simple model of course
no reactive power support and so on but
still if you look at the case of a
decreasing failure rate than this this
resource allocation problem is nice and
complex and you can solve it
and then if you do this numerically you
get solutions like this so you really
see if we look at a lot of 120% and we
need to decide what to do and we have
this performance criterion or we want to
meet we want to maximize the fraction of
people that meet their targets then the
the cars that will be parked at the end
of the street are going to get nothing
and in this Pareto case it is more
diffuse so of course this is this
criterion of like III now put a zero one
reward function you could also argue
that if I get charged enough so I can
make it home I'm also happy on the other
end maybe that's what we started with
that we already start at a bare minimum
so I mean it's just like a more
preliminary experiment but it's kind of
I found it at least interesting so now
just a little bit more on the urban math
so it's also related to an earlier
question of Stephen so if you look at
this the fluid model dynamic lead and
the you get like I mean it's not really
you can try to model this as you can
write down a partial differential
equation if you want but you can also
write it like this then its own then
it's not a differential equation anymore
it's a functional equation and the nice
you can prove here there's this nice
well there's this useful book also a
nice book of bones and Shapiro you open
up to page 261 I think and then you
apply that theorem and you can prove
that P of Z is Lipschitz continuous in
that and you can also show that P set is
non increasing and those two properties
together allows you to prove that the
set of equations has a unique solution
and so the question is how do you show
that there is a unique invariant points
you I mean you can if you're good in
finally up new functions go ahead I'm
not so but you can you you can exploit
the monotonicity of the system here so
it's a very nice trick that in a
different setting a former PhD student
of my mush of rock over
found and it's also applicable here so
essentially you define the living for
the limb sub you use some other
information to show that they're sitting
positivist if we finite and then when
you use these fluid equations to get a
set of equations for the limb infinite
limb sub which are given here and then
from the monotonicity of PZ and this
characterization of that star in terms
of this opf problem with the G criterion
function using a littles law you can you
can prove that this whole set of systems
has a unique solution and that gives you
the convergence okay so there are like
lots of so there is like a preprint on
the archive and that also contains the
multi class extension I mean they're
like we're currently working on a
rigorous justification of the fluid
scaling where we also try to do the AC
there are lots of things that are not in
here that's how the time-dependent
behavior is I think like steady-state
here is not probably not the most
interesting thing from a practical
standpoint I think the the utility
framework can be further refined
discretizing time might be an
interesting problem as well and of
course like having the buildings and the
fridges and the pizzas in the model that
would be also nice but for now this is
it thank you for your attention
[Applause]
function because it works well
mathematically I mean there are actually
better arguments that has all kinds of
nice properties and like like so in a
setting of communication networks Frank
Kelly you can also read that in his
textbook with UD Nova shows that even if
you don't know the utility function if
you use this weighted logarithmic
utility function and you set the weights
carefully you can achieve system-wide
optimum in a distributed fashion so
there are also good reasons and it also
happens to work mathematically very nice
yeah so up to some extent so the first
thing that we assume is indeed that we
the cars arrive at some rate lambda I
and and then if they if the final full
parking right they're lost then a
question of course in practice they're
not most they're going to read Park so
we actually got two years of charging
data we're from the TV campus and we
actually we don't know
physically partner but we have their
tags so we can we can actually we can
say okay
car number 1345 try to park here on
Monday but then on Tuesday arrive 10
minutes later and then when parking
there we're trying to now figure it out
how people behave from there I don't
know how far we'll get but yeah that
would be nice like to get some to get
some feeling on how people behave and
then included in the mall but I you
could also argue that for example if you
want to look at the University campus I
mean you have like like you enter like
with your track and then and then people
know you you enter and then you get an
app saying like there is still a
position available there that you have
some joint routing of I guess that the
parking of the car is like well it's
especially the beginning in the end of
the day but that you have some yeah that
you that you integrate this in a way
that would be nice of what of the cars
the test did taxi fleet yeah
that's true yeah so I guess like mobile
here I would say that you could say for
example okay somebody needs to get
charged and then you would like to know
that which are the nearest two locations
where there is space available to charge
and then you and then yeah we're
thinking in a context of battery
swapping on a about a model where we
have some power of two type of choice
where you you can can go like there are
like a bunch of locations close to you
and you take the one where there is the
most the capacity
[Applause]
[Music]